Democrats are voting for Nikki Haley
tonight in New Hampshire they're Biden
supporters check this Nikki Haley and
why did you vote for Nikki Haley uh it's
a vote against Trump um I think it would
be better to have her against Biden in
the uh elections than it would be Trump
and herur do you consider yourself
generally independent Republican or
Democrat uh Democrat so when you
Undeclared you voted for Nikki Haley if
it was Nikki Haley against Joe Biden in
a general election who are you voting
for Joe Biden what is the they outright
have no they have no Scruples they have
no
morals that that is like look I say the
banality of evil a lot but this is why
I've been I've been saying Civil War man
the process be damned to these people
Republicans keep playing this game of
look how magnanimous we are and the
Democrats keep laughing and trying to
knife them in the back here's a guy
who's saying your party's process means
nothing to me